the only thing i heard about richard on
paternity was that his backyard is
filled with deer [ __ ]
and he goes he bought a vacuum cleaner
that vacuums deer [ __ ]
they won't pick up bear [ __ ] though we
have bears [ __ ] in our backyard and
it's like huge jersey
we're in jersey there's a lot of
wildlife we had a fox
the other night like screaming it woke
us up in the front yard it was
like mating or something he's got like a
national geographic in his yard
i also heard that richard was peeing
into gatorade bottles so that he could
sprinkle his urine around the perimeter
of his backyard to keep the deer out
and that'll work that work it works yeah
it actually works real good my dad told
me because my dad
goes out on their front porch they had a
problem with coyotes coming up
to the house and like threatening our
dogs so my dad now pees in the yard
and it keeps the coyotes away he's
marking the territory saying
don't come and i say yeah yeah they
smell it like people
you can buy like uh tiger
i think tiger pea off the internet and
put it in your yard and it'll keep
supposedly keeps animals away because
they smell and they're scared
i tried that and the animals around here
is like there's no tigers around here go
[ __ ] yourself
we know we know where we live and then
the other thing i heard was that
you've befriended a raccoon and you've
been feeding it and i was going to tell
you not to do that because
yeah the raccoon's now hanging out at
your house and he could
you know they they say raccoons can have
rabies you know it's supposed to be
yeah they're so cute but why are certain
animals okay like in other words you're
you're
the deer are you keeping away but the
raccoons you like
we've seen the deer in our yard and our
son get such a kick out of it they're
cute
but if they didn't crap everywhere i'd
be totally fine with them being there
but the raccoon doesn't you know he
doesn't really crap or
he's not doesn't seem rabid so i have no
problem with him
he doesn't seem rabid right now but he
could wander off and get
around the wrong record well if he
starts slobbering i'm not feeding him
anymore
you